hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the lasker
combination a deadly way to attack your
opponent's king side this is a game that
he played in 1889 he was the world
champion for 27 years extremely talented
player and this will give us a better
insight into how we can attack our
opponents king side what things we
should be looking for all of that if
you're curious about the moves that got
us to this point i know some people do
like to play along i do have the entire
move list of the game as well as all the
moves that i'll be going over in this
video
in the description below you can
definitely check out that pgn so we'll
go ahead and get into it in this
position it's white's move and you can
see
that white has a lot of the material
eyeing on this king side of the board
this bishop here on e5 is attacking the
knight on f6 you have the bishop here on
d3 attacking the pawn here on h7 you
have the queen that can easily get
involved into the game coming here to h5
or g4 you have the knight that can swing
up here to h5 and you also have the rook
that can swing here to f3 and then two
g3 and h3 so a lot of attacking pieces
that white can get involved into the
game from black's perspective you can
see they don't have too many ways to
defend this knight here is being
protected by the bishop but beyond that
they start using their pawns and their
king is pretty exposed the queen here
and the bishop aren't doing too much the
rooks aren't really involved into the
game and many players they may come to a
position like this and not really
understand how they can continue this
will give you a good idea if you have
more pieces that can start to attack
your opponent's king side you just need
to look for combination in this position
lasker played the move knight to h5
his opponent took the knight here on
h5 with the thought of okay yeah we'll
just go ahead and exchange knights right
here
and then i'll be in a fairly
decent position yes the pawn here on h7
is now being attacked by the queen here
you know you could play pawn to g6 and
really stop a lot of that attack
but laska had different ideas instead of
after knight takes here on h5 instead of
taking with the queen here on h5
he played the move bishop takes on h7
more forceful approach to this
and then his opponent took here on h7
doesn't really do too much if he just
comes over here to h8 that's going to be
a losing proposition because now just
the queen takes here on h5
which you can see this is not going to
go well after
something like bishop here to g6 doesn't
really matter where black goes it's
going to end in a checkmate bb bishop
here to g5
bishop here g6 check
bishop here h6 but after the queen takes
this pawn is pinned down by this bishop
here uh so this is actually not going to
work and then after the king comes to g8
then queen here to h7 or
queen here 2 g7 both of those are going
to be checkmate so that does not work so
in the game this opponent correctly took
with his king here on
h7 instead of moving there to h8 but you
can start to see all the threats queen
here to h5 and now this opens up for the
rook to be able to get involved into the
game and attack the king here after the
king comes back here to
g8 now an additional sacrifice and that
is bishop takes here on
g7 and this is really
setting up for the threat of the queen
comes here to h8 because you if you look
at this same way i wouldn't take that
bishop i'll just go ahead and leave that
here it can't do that that will end in a
checkmate right away so does need to go
ahead and take this bishop here on g7
but after they do
queen 2 g4
king here 2 h7 uh it's not going to work
if they play king 2 h8 because rook here
2 f3 threatening swinging the rook over
here to h3 and they can try to stop it
with pawn two e5 to open up for the
queen to get involved to protect uh but
then after rook two h3 it's really just
delaying the inevitable after the queen
comes over here to h6 i can just go
ahead and take this and this is
checkmate but you can see how it's
different if the king is here on h7 and
that's why
black in the game played that king to
h7 so in the game
instead of the king 2 h8 we do see that
king 2 h7
white's going to continue same game plan
because the queen is going to fall so
rook 2 f3
pawn to e5 rook over here to h3 check
and then queen 2 h6 we do see the
exchange right here and then the move
queen to d7 in this spot black did
resign in the game because they're just
down too much it doesn't really matter
you can see the queen is attacking both
of these bishops
play could continue maybe rook over here
to e8 uh saying yes i know i'm gonna
lose one of these bishops here let's go
ahead and centralize my rooks
the bishop falls here maybe there's an
exchange on
this f4 square
the the queen can just start to gobble
up material you can see
white is up a lot of pawns compared to
black but also a queen compared to a
bishop in a rook
is definitely going to
win
just so much more horsepower in a queen
that they can use especially if you have
all these additional materials with the
ponds and the rook uh and with an
exposed king as well just makes it much
easier for white to dominate this game
so black did resign in this position
now that was the full lasker combination
but i want these videos to be extremely
instructional so
even if your opponent does not play all
the moves that you'll see you have a
good idea of how you may continue
so in this example the night taking here
on h5 it seems pretty reasonable but
it's actually a
bad move so they could try something
else one of the things that we talked
about is the bishop coming here to h7
and they can't really take here on h7
because we saw that was catastrophic but
they also can't come to h8 that would
end in checkmate pretty quickly so they
could try something like rook to
d8 wasn't played in the game but just
kind of showing you what could happen
and from here uh white still has some
really good options can take the knight
here after the bishop takes now we have
that in between move no reason to go
ahead and sacrifice yet because
we already know that if the king takes
here the queen's gonna
jump into the action right away and
check so instead the king kind of the
whole reason they played that knight
here to d8 is to move the king here to
f8 and now white can uh play the move
they could take that bishop if they want
to but i really like just clogging up
the center here with pawn to d4
and all of a sudden you can see whites
up a pawn and material with that h7
sacrifice or that h7 with the bishop
taking with the pawn sacrificing the
bishop that you know black cannot take
here things go south pretty quickly uh
both sides have their knights off the
board here and black can't castle is
king is
not in a safe spot so white can easily
get more material to attack his opponent
and white should have the upper hand
getting into the middle and the end game
so
even if your opponent doesn't take
exactly how you want to if you have one
side of the board that's overwhelmed
with material for in your advantage you
should definitely be looking at taking
advantage and trying to
take material on h7 take material on g7
get your queen and rook involved into
the game and really put a lot of
pressure on your opponent so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
looking at
a long time legend world champion alaska
in his deadly combination that he used
hopefully you guys can use some of this
knowledge in your own game and can start
to find some ways that you can win on
the kingside attack so thank you guys so
much for watching the video and i'll see
you guys in the next one